every year reporters and editors at
science choose several runners-up and
one breakthrough of the year before we
get to the breakthrough here are the
runners-up in Mexico researchers have
drilled rock cores from the Chicxulub
crater the cores Chronicle in
minute-by-minute detail the asteroid
impact that wiped out the dinosaurs
other studies have revealed how the
impact immediately destroyed living
things thousands of kilometers away and
how mammals and plants recovered in the
thousands of years that followed a team
of physicists claimed it's rudimentary
quantum computer performed a calculation
in 200 seconds that would overwhelm a
conventional supercomputer the
achievement is known as quantum
supremacy and it marks a significant
milestone on the long road to a fully
functioning quantum computer artificial
intelligence systems have conquered a
variety of complex two-person games but
this year a system called pluribus up
the ante it beat professional players in
thousands of six hand games of No Limit
Texas Hold'em poker a vastly more
complex challenge
Denisovans the extinct cousins of
Neanderthals have been known only by
scraps of fossils from a Russian cave in
Siberia but their genetic traces are
found in modern humans especially in
Melanesia and Australia this year
scientists used a new protein method to
identify a jaw bone found on the Tibetan
Plateau as Denisovan it's the first
physical trace of a Denisovan found
outside Siberia and another research
group used genetic data to reconstruct
the face of a Denisovan girl the search
for effective treatments for Ebola has
seen a string of disappointments but
this year two drugs tested during the
Ebola outbreak and the Democratic
Republic of the Congo dramatically
increased a patient's chance of survival
[Music]
NASA's new Horizons spacecraft
celebrated the New Year by relaying
images of an icy object from the far
reaches of the solar system 1.6 billion
kilometres beyond Pluto it looks like
two merged lumpy pancakes researchers
believe it hasn't been disturbed since
the formation of the solar system and it
holds clues to how planets form
a series of studies has indicated that
some severely malnourished children
recuperates slowly if at all because
their gut microbes remain in an immature
State this year researchers came up with
nutritional supplements that help the
gut flora in these children recover
paving the way for more effective
treatments a drug combination approved
this year in the United States aims to
turn cystic fibrosis from a
progressively damaging lung disease into
a manageable chronic illness for most
patients the treatment which counteracts
the effects of a genetic mutation
carried by 90% of cystic fibrosis
patients comes 30 years after
researchers identified the gene behind
the disease this year microbiologist
took a major step toward understanding
the origin of eukaryotes the group that
includes plants animals and other
organisms with cell nuclei after 12
years of trying they succeeded in
culturing a microbe that belongs to an
elusive group called Asgard archaea they
are the closest relatives to eukaryotes
according to recent DNA analyses now
researchers have this missing link in
hand to study and now the breakthrough
of the year
in a technical tour de force astronomers
combined observations from dozens of
radio telescope dishes at eight
observatories around the globe to
generate the first image of a black hole
the image shows a ring of light
surrounding a supermassive black hole at
the center of a galaxy 53 million
light-years from Earth science is
recognizing this impressive
international collaboration and its
impact on our understanding of the
cosmos as the 2019 breakthrough of the
year
[Music]